welcome back to my tutorial series on
creating a data science blog if you
haven't already check out part one of
the series where i show you how to get
your website up and running
in this video we're going to cover how
to add blog posts to our site in a few
different ways
i'll show you how to create posts
manually then from jupyter notebooks
then from our studio
and finally how to embed interactive
visualizations into your pages
but before we get started let's talk
about how posts work in jekyll they can
either be html
or markdown documents and the file name
must follow a specific convention
with the date first and then the title
also if the date in the file name is
after today's date
it actually won't show up on your
website it'll only appear live
after that date so let's get started
we're first going to run our jekyll
server again
so bundle exec check will serve and once
it starts
running we can go ahead and open up our
server and just take a look at our
website so we'll go over to posts and
you see that we have all these posts
here
that mirror the post letter in our
folder here so i'm actually going to get
rid of these
i'm going to get rid of all but one of
them for now just so we have one we can
reference
but i also don't want this to still show
up on our website so i'm going to create
a new folder
called drafts and then i'm going to move
this file into there
any of your posts that's underneath this
drafts folder won't actually
show up on your website additionally a
lot of those posts
had images that are all contained within
this image folder
so i'm going to go ahead and delete all
of those
great so now if we go back to our site
and refresh we should have no posts
which is exactly what i want
so let's start with making our first
blog post so as i mentioned before we
can either make an html or a markdown
file but i'm going to stick with
markdown because they're more readable
easier to write and they still do
support html snippets
but if you're unfamiliar with markdown
or just want a refresher on the syntax
check out the markdown guide over here
but it's pretty easy to follow
so to make our new post we're just going
to go back to our post folder make a new
file
and then for the file name again we have
to follow that specific naming
convention
with the year dash month dash
day and then whatever arbitrary title we
want
i'm going to make this post about web
scraping so i'm just going to call it
web scraping and then dot md for
markdown
now for jekyll to know that this is a
post and then appropriately format
our data for the website we need to add
the yaml front matter at the top
so i'm going to go back to this file
that i put in drafts and just copy this
just so we know what we need to add so
i'm going to keep the layout post
for title this is going to be about web
scraping in r
for the subtitle i'm just going to make
it scraping movie data from imdb with
rfs package
i'm actually going to remove the state
from here because i'm not sure if it
even shows up on the website anywhere
and then for background i'm going to
replace this later but this is the big
banner that shows up behind our title
of our post alright so now we've got our
yaml front matter in i'm going to add
the actual content
of our post just underneath and i'm
actually just going to copy and paste
this in
there isn't too much going on here it's
mostly just headers
some code snippets some links so we're
going to save it and just take a look
at our website so let's refresh we see
web scraping in r
again we haven't set that background yet
so right now this is just a gray box
and i see that we have one broken image
link
so let's go ahead and fix that so i'm
actually going to remove this image link
and the basic syntax for adding images
in markdown
you need to have an exclamation mark and
then in brackets the alt text and then
in parentheses
the link to that image but this is the
image that i want to
embed into my post so what i'm going to
do is go to my image
posts and then i'm actually going to
make a new folder called
web scraping and for each of my posts
i'm actually going to have a new folder
just so i can keep
all the images for that post in separate
folders and not just in one big
directory but then i'll just drag that
same image into that folder and now i
just need to copy
the relative path and paste it and i
will actually need to add a slash here
so it goes into the image folder but
once i save that and go
back refresh i should see it
the only issue is that it's way wider
and bigger than i need it to be
but we can fix this with some really
basic css so i'm going to go into our
assets folder
into vendor to our scss files
and from the template there is a css
file for post
and this is pretty simple i'm just going
to add an image tag
and make the width a hundred percent
i can save that go back to our site and
refresh
and now our image actually fits within
our content and looks a lot better
the last thing i'm going to do is just
add the background image for our post
so i'll go back to web scraping i've got
another image
that i'm going to drag into that same
folder we're going to copy the relative
path
and then paste it in our background and
again we have to add that slash here so
it knows to go into our image folder
we can save it and we'll go back to our
site refresh
and you see that it shows up right there
so that wasn't too difficult but what if
we had let's say a jupiter notebook with
a python project
and want to make that into a blog post
well here i've got a jupyter notebook
that i found
online i'll put a link to this in the
description um i actually deleted a lot
of the code just to make it a bit
simpler but you can see we have a
visualization down here
and some other code snippets headers
write up etc but once we're in our
notebook all we need to do is go to file
download as markdown and it'll actually
create a zip file that we can open up
and that zip file is going to contain
the main markdown file and then
any kind of image or figures that were
part of that notebook
so we're going to go back to vs code and
i'm going to drag
census.md into posts now we just need to
do a couple things that we did before
first is renaming it to fit that same
naming convention
so i'll call this 2021.01 and we're just
going to date this
for yesterday assuming that i wrote this
post yesterday and now we just need to
add that yaml front matter
so we're going to copy that over from
here
we'll change up the title to u.s census
data visualizing the us population
now we'll still need to set a background
and we'll also need to fix
the link for this image at the very
bottom but that isn't too difficult
since we just did that
so i'm going to go back to our image
folder and posts
and make a new folder called census
i'm going to drag in that one image of
our jupiter notebook
output and then i've also got this
background image for our post
that i'm going to drag in as well i'll
copy that relative path
go back to our post and paste it in
make sure i add the slash and then i'll
do the same with our
figure so paste our relative path
and add the slash we can save this we
can open up our
link again and we see our new post
and our image works great so what if
you're in r studio and you're working
with an r notebook it's again pretty
straightforward
you will need to install the r markdown
package so install that packages are
markdown
and then when you're creating your file
you'll want to create a new r markdown
from template and use github document
markdown
and make sure that the output is github
document but i'm going to close this and
open up a file that i just recently
worked on
so what's interesting here is i actually
have an r notebook that uses
an interactive plotly graph and if you
want to know how to do this i actually
have a video on making interactive maps
that i'd recommend checking out but
anyway i'm going to click run
and just run all these cells and you can
see this is what the output of our graph
looks like
but if we want to get this embedded into
our post it's actually not too difficult
here where we're displaying the graph
instead what we need to do
is we need to create a new line and use
the html widgets package
and we're going to call the save widget
command with as
widget function we're going to pass in
the name of our graph
and then what we want to name the file
and i'm just going to name it
minwage graph.html and then i can delete
this line
and i'll save it so now we can knit our
document and it just shows us a preview
of our markdown file
so we'll close out of it but in our
folder we should see three files
the original our markdown file a normal
markdown file and then that html file
along with any other figures or images
that you would have knitted so we're
going to follow the same
steps that we did before to get our
markdown as a post
so we'll drag in our mark down to our
post folder we'll rename it i'm going to
call this
interactive maps we need to add our yaml
front matter so let's copy it put it in
here
we'll call this interactive maps in r
creating interactive maps with the
plotly package
and then we'll make a new folder for our
post called interactive
maps we'll put our minwagecraft.html in
there
just like we would do if it was an image
and i'm also going to put this other
image
that i found online of this cool map
we'll go back to our post
copy the relative path for our
background
we're also going to copy the relative
path of our html
and this is where we want it to be
displayed so i'm actually going to
remove this rcode snippet right here
and instead of just doing a standard
image we actually have to
embed some html code so we're going to
use the iframe tag
and our source is going to be that
relative url
but again we need to have the slash
before it and then we can close
the iframe at the end so if we save this
we can take a look at our website
refresh let's go back to our posts
interactive maps in r
and we get kind of a really small
squished graph
can't really see any of the data so
we're actually going to go back here
oh i realize that i can also remove
these warnings
but we're going to go back here into our
html tag and we're going to make the
height
800 pixels and the width we're just
going to make it 100
we'll go back refresh and you see that
we do get
our embedded map now and it works
perfectly and you can essentially do
this with any kind of
interactive html figure in your blog
so the last thing we need to do just to
get our changes to show up live on our
real website is go ahead and commit them
i'll just write a commit message
added posts yes and then we need to push
our changes down here
and once it's done being pushed once you
refresh your github repo you'll see that
it has our newest commit
but once we go to dataslice.github.io it
should take a second for the post to
actually show up but i'm gonna refresh
and you see that we now have our changes
we have our new posts
with both the images and the interactive
components all working so that's pretty
much it for this tutorial in the next
video we're going to go into more
further customizations and
really how to make your website your own
so definitely be on the lookout for that
but if you have any questions feel free
to leave a comment below and i'll try to
get back to you
anyway thanks for watching and i'll
catch you in the next one